Our studio just got a massive upgrade and
it has to do with maps. And I– just watch
this. Oh, yeah! Now we're talking. Now we have
a map of the world. We have a map of the United
States. We have a map of the massive, beautiful
states of Hawaii and Alaska. Oh, we're just
getting started. Nick, let's get another one. That
one right there. Yes, please. All made possible
by this beautiful mounting hardware. Oh, yeah.
Unravel. My favorite map of all time. We've got
Switzerland. Oh, my gosh. Look at that beautiful
topa-. I mean, look at this. Look at this. This
kind of stuff makes me swoon. Just the most
gorgeous map of all time. And we have atlases,
road maps of Europe from, like, the 1970s and the
old maps here and stuff from, like, the 1400s or
something. This is where I work and this is where
I also look at maps. Some are just like hanging on
the wall, too, you know? All right, let's see the
big boy. This is a new one. Yep. Here it comes.